if you say well i'm going to take this
take this role because i can be really
great in it
and i'm going to do it better than
anybody else well that's something that
you
really have no control over whether
that's going to happen or not but you
have more control over whether it's
going to happen that you're going to
learn something
why is acting in exercise and empathy it
has a lot to do with the judgment issue
with
feeling
that
there's
that every character is doing what they
think is right what they think is best
they have a reason everybody has a
reason for everything that they do
i once read a short story
um and unfortunately i don't remember
the author but it was a wonderful short
story
and it had this line
there's a reason for everything and
sometimes too
and i've just always clashed that
to my heart
as
something very essential about
acting about script analysis about
directors understanding actors and
understanding characters everybody has a
reason for what they're doing it might
be a reason that the rest of us would
look at from the outside and say that's
a crappy reason that's a stupid reason
that's a wrong reason of course we we
all have the the audience has the right
to judge
but but the actor
has to come from a place of you know
what the that they
that the character is operating out of a
need they they need something
and
they're they're doing what they can to
get there so
so it's deeply empha empathetic
um and i and i actually believe that
that acting is
a kind of spiritual practice i'm one of
those and one of those people that that
feels that way about it uh for myself
when i got into acting i i had no i had
no notion of making a career at it i had
no notion i certainly had no notion of
being a movie star or
or
anything like that i i was was the 1970s
and i was looking for
something to do that would
be fulfilling that would make me
understand the world better and
understand myself better
acting was perfect
partly because of my wonderful teacher
who
just seemed to know so much about life
and about why people do things why why
characters do the things they do
and also why people do the things they
do
so
it was always very personal for me
i i always it was always a learning
uh
a learning
experience
learning about myself
learning about the world learning why
people do the things they do
and um
and and so that's certainly an exercise
in empathy
i think
i i i always try to ask directors to
expect that that's what actors are there
for
that they're students of life
that they want to
know more
about about people and about the world
and that if directors approach them that
way as artists and as ethical people
that they will
be able to communicate better and be
able to communicate their vision better
would you see actors that had different
levels of empathy maybe empathy toward
their scene partner but less so with
themselves and that became a problem in
their performances
can you give me an example well you know
how some people are incredibly harsh on
themselves whether it's
you know something that's been said to
them in the past that they carry with
them
so then they they always carry that
everywhere they go and maybe they would
take that in a scene and they might
treat their scene partner well
but then for themselves the empathy
wasn't there
actors are no total
actors are notoriously hard on
themselves
always
90
there's you know to the extent that when
you hear a story of an actor who's not
hard on themselves i'm going to give you
one in a second it's really exciting and
amazing and and it blows uh other actors
minds there's a story about meryl streep
that i read in an article it was an
interview with chris cooper who played
opposite her in adaptation
and he said that every every time
that a take got blown or or didn't work
or she made a mistake or or something
went wrong she would after that just go
huh
okay let's go it again and she never
lost her
her joy
of acting she never came down on herself
she never she never uh
many actors after that something
happened so go oh
and she never did that and he was
shocked he'd never seen it
so i would say
you know 90 percent or 99
maybe of actors are very hard on
themselves and then those sparkling
one percent or 10 percent are are
unusual
but of course they have so much freedom
and of course you want
actors to have that kind of freedom and
i've taught actors for a long time to
acting classes and i always wanted them
to have that freedom to forgive
themselves to
to uh and that that's why i say to
directors
you know permission to fail is the most
valuable thing that you can give an
actor is you you can tell them
uh
don't worry we'll do it again if if i
won't use anything that doesn't work
so um
we have all the time in the world and
even telling an actor we have all the
time in the world even if you don't
you'll actually get the shot faster than
if you uh say to an actor okay we've
only got one more we only got time for
one more shot so we've got to get it on
this shot
it it's actually less likely to go well
than if you say you know we've got all
the time in the world let's just do one
more
and uh you're more likely to get
something good out of out of that
permission to fail that it's okay if you
fail
would you see empathy
um the degrees of empathy
maybe blossom more let's say there's a
scale and when a student would come to
you in the past uh for the the classes
that in you know the workshops uh that
their empathy they were closed off and
you could see it in them whether it was
family conditioning and then over time
the scale that they came more to this
side where
they just were open open to themselves
open to other people well that was
always my hope of course
it's always my hope
i i try not to make myself responsible
for
whether that happens or not but but it's
always my hope that that people will
that
whether they're acting or whether
they're directing that uh or whether
they're writing that it will open them
up that it will that it will uh connect
them more to
to uh
what they what they feel is important
about life and
and i
i used to feel this way when i was an
actor myself when i was in plays i was
in plays a lot all during the 70s
and
and i
used to approach every role
with the idea that once the show closed
i would know more about myself
than i did at the start of rehearsal
and i think that
i think that's that helped because
that's something that really can happen
if you say well i'm going to take this
take this role because i can be really
great in it
and i'm going to do it better than
anybody else well that's something that
you
really have no control over whether
that's going to happen or not but you
have more control over whether it's
going to happen that you're going to
learn something
so i always i always think of that as a
good it's a good place to come from for
anybody in the arts
that if your goal on any project is to
learn something then you really can't go
wrong you will you'll you will reach
your goal if your goal is to learn
something you will reach that goal if
your goal is to be perfect to be to be
great to blow everybody out of the water
well there's
i don't know there's a lot of room for
disappointment
you